investigators say they finally solved a
mystery that made national headlines
over the killing of eight family members
in rural Ohio a husband wife and their
two adult sons who lived nearby were
charged with aggravated murder yesterday
in 2016 almost an entire family was
found beaten and shot to death in a
small town that's just south of Columbus
David beg no has been following the
story since the beginning David good
morning good morning to you Nora
eight members of the Rhoden family were
found shot to death inside of four
different homes in Pike County Ohio now
shortly after the killings I spoke with
a law enforcement official who told us
that there was a marijuana grow
operation on the property that the
victims lived on and that true concerns
that the grisly killings could have been
the work of a gang or even a cartel hit
but yesterday when the cops said who the
suspects were people were shocked to
find out the suspects of the neighbors
we promised that the day would come when
arrest would be made in the pike County
massacres today is that day
Ohio's Attorney General Mike DeWine
called this investigation into the 2016
murders the longest and most complex in
the state's history on the night of
April 22nd 2016 8 members of the Rhoden
family were killed in four separate
locations they had all been shot in the
head and some of them were killed as
they slept for more than two years
police followed thousands of tips and
conducted hundreds of interviews and the
trail eventually led them right to the
victims neighbors George Wagner the
third his wife Angela along with their
two adult sons George the fourth and
Edward who's known as Jake one family
conspired planned carried out and then
allegedly covered up their violent act
to wipe out members of another family
police save for months leading up to the
massacre the suspects studied the layout
of the victims homes their routines even
their sleeping patterns 19 year old
Hannah Roden was killed as she slept
next to her five day old infant she had
had a daughter and was sharing custody
with one of the suspects 26 year old
Jake Wagner they did this quickly coldly
calmly and very carefully police say the
Wagner family left behind a trail of
evidence including forged documents
investigators believe it was an
obsessive custody battle that may have
played a role in the killings we're a
place that doesn't let cowardly
murderers get away with their crimes
under the cover of darkness we should
point out the suspects move to Alaska at
one point and they were interviewed by a
local news reporter and they denied
being involved at all but but to think
about I remember that one woman who died
the young woman who was sleeping right
next to her newborn baby she was shot
and killed in the head and the baby was
sleeping and the baby's father is one of
the suspects bingo it's such a grisly
gruesome story thank you David